[ __ ] you Ben you're bleeding from your
mouth what happened this morning Bob Lee
know somebody pulled your hair outside
on the side then he came here bleeding
whatever I know I must have [ __ ] been
flossing too hard so you've lost in the
morning too I try to I'm not good at it
I mean I'm looking teeth no they blow a
red guy what happened to Matt I'm gonna
have to check when I get home and see if
I have to go to the dentist but uh would
you cut it I must have a go I went in
the back and I was bleeding a little bit
but I mean I'm fine it was tough as
[ __ ] nails I'd bleed all the time who
gives a [ __ ] he's possibly teeth fall
out who gives a [ __ ] what's happening
beautiful people the Churchill what's
happening now we're here sorry by
yesterday as you people know I got a
colonoscopy thank you for all your
wishes and for asking and for sending
loves and then last night the [ __ ]
guests cancelled at like 10:00 to 6:00
he was sick he's been sick for a while
you know I was gonna get this acting guy
and he coached me through analyzed that
his name is Jimmy de Stefano he's uh
he's running the Actors Studio now in
Hollywood needs a [ __ ] great guy from
biggies from the Islander some I've
known him for like 15 years and he got
sick so we were left in a bind I didn't
want to give you guys a 50% podcast I
wasn't up to par the [ __ ] anesthesia
what happened I never realized this
yesterday they wouldn't let me leave
drove me down I want to thank Lee for
picking me up at 5:30 you know anybody
people always want to pick you up and
you got something in your ass you know
I'm saying if you call something I got
to go in I [ __ ] you no no I gotta go to
this place if I stick a camera in my ass
no [ __ ] I'll be there 5:15 you know he
was outside ready to laugh and giggle
you had to blog you with him I was gonna
say if they were to let us in do into a
podcast that would have been the number
one podcast ever recorded oh my god my
[ __ ] fainted
III fainted when they put the IV in my
hand because I hadn't eaten for 24 hours
I went in there and I was thinking about
it and it was warming there and they put
the [ __ ] thing in and the needles
shocking my body I mean it didn't even
[ __ ] hurt just the thought of it
you're mine
and it's a [ __ ] up thing and it's just
the thought of it gave me I always go
into these skunk sweats like I feel
sweat all over it's like a light layer
or a mist that just comes out of me when
I'm about to faint or whatever I didn't
faint I had Santana on the iPod but
besides that I got paid man it wasn't a
bad experience at all I have got on on
the internet on like Wednesday or Monday
or something and checked out different
diets leading up to it and what I should
do and I listened to some of them but
the main thing I didn't listen to was
the fear part people were already saying
you know that the stuff to drink is
terrible it's amazing when you let
people get into your head mm-hmm before
you it's like anything else
it's like being at home for dinner with
your family and going you know what
tonight I'm gonna go down to a local
thing I'm gonna get on stage and save
poetry why would you want to do
something like that don't you know that
sucks you know and it's so weird how
sometimes you let the negative comments
affect you but sometimes you just steam
like through it like I thought the drink
you have to drink a potion 24 hours
before they stick the camera up the
[ __ ] because it cleans out your colon
but everybody said that the thing was
very tough to drink and I was a little
apprehensive because I don't like taste
like I don't drink milk because of the
taste I don't like vegetables because
the taste texture and taste have
destroyed me know the Dolce died is a
great die I see people losing weight
with all the time I just don't like a
lot of those things you know I don't
like tofu the texture of tofu I don't
like a lot of that [ __ ] yeah and I even
my dad was working when I won eight when
I called him and told him he was like oh
that's a and that thing is terrible
doesn't taste good and then when I pick
you up over here listen not being
[ __ ] taste good but this was clear
number one this was clear which really
helped a lot
because I thought it was gonna be like
milk a [ __ ] magnesia with a weird
taste but it was clear
my wife put two packages of
crystallizing lemon lime mhm and a
little bit of water I think he's
supposed to dilute it and guys I put a
straw in it so it only hits the back of
your throat that's what a lot of people
said make it very cold and I put the
straw back in I just started chugging
and every chug it was I did it every
glass and three chugs and it's crazy
because the first
time I thought my [ __ ] was just going
to blow up yeah blood on the walls and
that's the message it didn't happen for
about an hour and then it was like a
slow every twenty minutes I have to [ __ ]
but I had to be careful couldn't make a
laugh or couldn't make that everything
was right there it was coming right out
you know was the whole time but I got to
tell you I'm happy I did it I'm happy I
did it because it does save lives and a
lot of people reached out and said that
you know they had a relative but it
saved their life so thank you very much
you know last night a lot of people were
mad you said that somebody said to you
that you shouldn't treat our fans like
that first of all if somebody listens to
this show and thinks they're a family
show don't listen to the show no man do
me a favor I don't want no fans
I want boring Network and we understand
each other last night
Lee and I went to meet with somebody and
like 6:30 and the guy when you shut the
[ __ ] up so by the time we realized it
was 8 o'clock it was too late to tweet
but when I got home I tweeted I'm sorry
of you people made plans around it but
sometimes you know the guess it's it's I
want to give you guys the best possible
podcast I can so I'm sorry and now we're
gonna start the week off on the right
[ __ ] foot Lee I got up at 2 in
the morning by mistake I went to pee I
stayed in bed like 30 minutes and I
couldn't do it no more I got up yeah a
little coffee I even hit the pipe this
morning oh 3:00 in the morning outside
on my balcony I was coughing this show
I'm like what the [ __ ] neighbors
think they're you living like a doctor
I'm living like a [ __ ] back though
what happened you yesterday at the movie
theatres you want to see James Brown
yeah which is really freaking amazing
when did the movie come out Friday I
think so and it was it was the theater
was em there was a one o'clock one
o'clock it was like one of the first
times I I mean I had heard about him but
I know you liked him I know you showed
Rogan that was that one video that one
time on this podcast but I I knew his
music but I didn't really know that much
about him so it was really good and
Chadwick Boseman did a great job that
guy but it's uh there's something like
do you have anything about you that you
I hate to use this final leg Jesus word
but I hate about yourself
Oh worse it's just everything yeah and
I've always been I don't know if it's
because I was chopping away
my personality I don't like
confrontation and I don't like I'm not
good at standing up for myself uh I was
I was now bully bullies overused now I
had bullies but it wasn't I think I did
too happy childhood but I don't like
when people take advantage or people say
something and I always I'm always the
one in my head I'm thinking of eight
thousand things later that day to say
but I never say it in the moment so this
one guy sat down and what just asked
I'll make noise with the popcorn I wish
I'd said something but what really got
to me was and I hate that it stings that
it got to me but there's a few people on
Twitter who and I see you mess with them
and that's what I would love to do it's
the people who say stuff I think it's
just to piss you off but like just some
evil stuff like like when I was I was
just mad that they were saying they were
sitting so I tweeted about it because I
don't know I'm an idiot but they're like
get off your fat ass I'm like what do
you say that to someone in public like
it's just that's not part of me at all
and then it like it I wanted to say
something but then I didn't want to get
into war with them this morning
when I came in here you said to me as a
joke with giggling you said we should
get the earphones with the mouthpiece on
it yeah and I replied we're gonna be two
fat [ __ ] with looking like yeah yeah
two fat [ __ ] astronauts you know did
I mean that with malice no did I hurt
your feelings when I said there now it's
the way people say that yeah it's not
how you say it's the way people say
things I'm having guilty of it also
sometimes without realizing but you got
understand saying to you what love is it
goofy
yeah yeah I don't mind [ __ ] around
with people but if I don't know you
don't cross that [ __ ] line right cuz
I never cross it
I was raised never to cross that line so
I would never cross that line when I
first got the longest yard and I went
out on the road after long as yard it
was some the things people said to me
were mind-bogglingly
they said things to me that didn't even
want me to I didn't want to go on the
road anymore public in public like to be
cute and for their girlfriends or to
test themselves those people I look at
and I [ __ ] pray for we were in Vegas
somebody made a comment some jerk-off
down the line and let me got next to me
he goes this is the first time I've been
close to this a Mexican yeah yeah I
wanted to smack him in the mouth but I
pray for him or you could do as he walks
away say you know what I hope you don't
run into somebody who doesn't understand
yeah
and that's gonna happen for those
jerk-offs those are the people that you
walk out of a bar and they're on the
floor and their girlfriends going you an
[ __ ] to the guy and the guy's
bleeding from his mouth and he's passed
out that's that guy yeah that's that guy
that goes over borders there's always
people that there's a line there's a
line of those are the people that
weren't accepted in that you know and
they try to be cute in front of their
girlfriends I see it all the time I see
it once a month I walk out of somewhere
I'm in a comedy club and there's a
circle and there's a guy on the [ __ ]
floor bleeding and the girlfriend he
didn't say nothing he didn't mean it yes
he did he thought he was cute and that's
what happens after 10 o'clock on Twitter
you have this this I don't need that you
don't know what my face looks like yeah
you know what if you want to call me out
and I go to your page and you have a
real page I will look for the reason why
you would say something like that and I
will say something pushing and you'll
push back a joke you know I love you
okay but there's people who just get on
I don't understand those people I don't
understand who would wake up in the
morning go you know what today I'm gonna
set up a [ __ ] I'm gonna set up a fake
Twitter page and I'm gonna call Dana
ball [ __ ]
I'm gonna call djaro gonna call a bull
[ __ ] I'm gonna call D as a fat [ __ ] I'm
gonna call Li a Jew I never understood
that I never understood that those are
the things I don't comprehend yeah but
that's our society today there's people
who think that cute somebody sent that
read to me the other day from reddit and
it's amazing people said there were
misogynist I'm a misogynist that mr.
Church of what's happening now but I
always talk about the past the reason
why I talk about the past on
surely the reason why I tell a story
every episode is because I feel you know
you have this thing I'm very insecure
and you're growing up I was very
insecure and after my mother from the
ages of 28 to 30 I was a ball in
security and we all are we don't know
what our next move is we don't know you
know there's some people know but 60% of
us if you're listening for this [ __ ]
podcast you were one of those people
that you were a little scared maybe you
didn't know what you want to do in your
confused and I was one of those people
that was very very [ __ ] insecure I
think you have it all so you know you
walk into a room I don't like that feel
that's what I don't like
mm-hmm and after I feel insecure about
something I look what's going on I go
you know what [ __ ] these [ __ ]
nobody is better than me in this [ __ ]
room and I tell these stories I tell the
stories about me waking up next to a
piece of [ __ ] I tell the stories of me
robbing people or me stick of Steel on
the [ __ ] change jar you think I like
telling those stories you think anybody
else would have the honesty to tell
those stories on the air
but I want you to understand that people
could change that is what I talk about
in this thing that when I [ __ ] up
we've just gone through a bad [ __ ]
spell we change and you evolve as a
human being as you if you don't you're a
[ __ ] idiot if you don't [ __ ]
evolve as so you know when I see those
people on Twitter that send I don't know
if it's an insecurity I don't know if
it's their thing all you could do is
just look up and go whatever God Hindu
black whatever just and that's what I do
that's what I always do and no everyone
else has take the high road but just
like and not even them personally but
like okay I was at the gym and I was I
was out I was at the bench taking stuff
out of my bag in front of a locker and
this guy just moved in and took the
locker from me and it's not a big thing
I just got in another Walker but like I
wanted to be that couple like hey man
that's my Walker like that's not even a
big thing that's a doll and it probably
wouldn't have been even been a fight but
it's I don't like in myself that I'm I
don't know if it's shyness or insecure I
don't know what it is and
I don't know what I don't know exactly
what to do to fix it say something oh it
makes me so nervous say something and
you'll get it over with and don't say it
call the guy in a so just go scuse me
that's my locker bro you know or excuse
me sir can you stop with the popcorn I'm
trying to watch a movie you know yeah I
would love to I would you know I don't
understand
first off again you're at a movie
theater the movie theatres empty well
these two jerk-offs a me understand me
these are you got to look at those
[ __ ] and go you [ __ ]
[ __ ] there's a huge feeder in your
tufa seized from me that's what I hate
when they go to restaurants - you got a
restaurant the house sits people on
Tapia restaurant attempt to get these
[ __ ] people away from me right I want
to spread out maybe there's three of us
in we're talking about eating [ __ ] and
stabbing a [ __ ] and this [ __ ] guy
family of kids next to me now we gotta
sit here like [ __ ] mutes because you
you don't want the way to go from one
end to the other [ __ ] him [ __ ] him
that's his [ __ ] job you know
yeah it's least say something say
something I had the same problem when I
first got here I had the same [ __ ]
problem and I wouldn't say none for two
reasons I didn't want nobody I think I
was a bad guy and my addiction I didn't
want nobody to [ __ ] up my addiction and
then one day I started talking and then
when I got off the addiction I started
talking and now they don't like me but
when I open my mouth it's because I'm
protecting myself I'm not opening my
mouth to be a jerk-off I'm opening my
mouth to say hey enough yeah whatever
the [ __ ] you think you're doing you're
not gonna do I'm not opening my mouth to
fight nobody I'm an old man I got
problems I had been in prison I don't
want to fight nobody I mean no I don't
have time for that [ __ ] but you do have
your space in this life and that's all
you have you know we were talking
earlier about these people now that
everybody's taking sides you know we
live in a society where it's cool to
take sides or it's cool to open up your
mouth without really knowing what's
going to [ __ ] on mmm and I was very
scared when I got to LA I was insecure
again I was a young comic I wanted to do
well I wanted people to like me I'm
gonna be likeable so for years people
said [ __ ] and I didn't say nothing one
night I was at the store and I walked
back there and some comedian Wilde
Worley Parsons brought me up and he said
something about me till this day I think
about it assistant but you know
I was wild Willie Parsons to it he's
[ __ ] irrelevant yeah so it doesn't
really [ __ ] matter what he said or
what he didn't [ __ ] say you know to
his dad look the [ __ ] punch him in
the [ __ ] head those old-style comics
but you know what
I took the [ __ ] the high road yeah
and I looked at him and I put it in
God's hands and I'm still here what a
[ __ ] is he
yeah what the [ __ ] what was the last TV
show he did was last [ __ ] reality
show he did what was the last anything
he [ __ ] did so you follow me when you
call somebody out like then maybe you
should think about yourself what the
[ __ ] you doing but we say something say
something and it doesn't have to be you
know in a bad way just please say
something so you make yourself feel
better you know when I want to go to the
colonoscopy today I got to drive down to
jujitsu I'm going down to where we were
yesterday around them Wilshire to go to
Riga Machado's at 10 o'clock ask me if I
want to go there how long you know me I
don't even like driving for the [ __ ]
school but it's time you know it's time
to get out of your [ __ ] comfort zone
yeah you know sometimes you have to give
so I'm gonna go down there house we'll
call them for spots at the Comedy Store
this week you know Tommy got fired from
the economy starts with a big deal
around town I didn't give a [ __ ] that
Tommy got fired or not you know I just
wanna I know there's something missing
from my life I know that during the week
I only do spots like I'll drop in a
flappers on Wednesdays I go to the haha
and not to put the hard down or to put
flappers down you know though birds at
the store Marc Maron's at the store
Ari's at the store you know Sebastian
Maniscalco at the store there's all
these comics and that's the a leak and
if you want to play in the a-league
that's where I have to go it's my home
that's where I developed as a comic
that's where I I [ __ ] myself up and
made myself a man so I'm gonna go back
this weekend and do some spots you know
somebody call me for a weekend fallout
so I'm gonna wait today and see and I
just called in for Wednesday and
Thursday because I had the podcast and I
didn't know about them I even go down
there tonight if I have nothing to do
just to see it say hello and whatever
because you know I'm not gonna sit here
and preach going out of your comfort
zone that I don't do it myself
yeah and I thought about it yesterday
when I hung up we're Hagan Machado I go
what am I
can going down to class down then I go
it's time to get out of my [ __ ]
company
I don't have much going on for me I
wrote this morning I'm gonna go down
there [ __ ] go to jiu-jitsu come back
wash my [ __ ] go to acupuncture and take
it to the park yeah that's my [ __ ]
bakery
no that's it's uh even even on me to go
to a class of the gym now and part of it
is that odd you sorry what
you shy you know how do you not tip Top
Chef something like you think you're
gonna have to leave after 30 minutes
perfect yeah just walk into the class if
it starts at 8:15 look at the clock and
go if I make it to 8:30 today I'm good
and then when you go next week some
chicks on a car to you go hey man what
happened to us who are you okay you go
you know I wasn't in shape my calf was
bothering me I got a cramp
I didn't drink enough whatever you have
to say but you keep going yeah and you
keep trying them and you may not like it
hey I belong to the why I've taken
simple stretch at the why I've taken
simple stretch I take it all the yoga's
I've taken Tai Chi at the Y
I've taken the cardio fit at the why I
take the spin class at the Y I've broken
it up over the years I don't go anymore
because I like the teachers like there
was a one spin teacher that her husband
was a kickboxing so half a workout was
kicking and then she put you on the bike
and really run your legs
she left oh okay then I had the chick
who called in here
I forget what her name is off the bat
she was a great yoga teacher then she
left you know so you get accustomed to
the teachers now I'm dying to go back to
the Y to a class I went Saturday took
mercy swimming and my wife did the yoga
well I took mercy swimming I don't know
if I told you about that what a [ __ ]
day that was oh wow no he didn't a lot
of [ __ ] kids in that damn class
yeah it's just my my whole personality
is is to kind of not be seen I guess
like I I I always go to the back of the
ellipticals I just know I'm not the big
out there kind of guy so go into the
class I wouldn't even know where to
stand I just go back to the [ __ ]
clothes it's stupid things to think
about watch but it's yet I do
and as you get
better you move up because then people
are coming after you and they're gonna
go to the back of the class and then you
move up and now they start watching you
it's a [ __ ] evolutionally don't ever
be embarrassed about taking care of
yourself don't ever be in back you're
gonna be surprised how many people gonna
be very supportive oh that everyone's
been greater than everybody everybody
listen when you're talking about health
now and what people going through
everybody wants you to succeed when you
want a gym it's the weirdest [ __ ]
thing you know you asking me man you're
going more more than Jitsu no you know
what everybody wants me to succeed even
though they know I'm [ __ ] horrible
I'm horrible yeah it doesn't matter if I
don't keep going this is anything if I
don't keep showing what I talk on this
[ __ ] podcast with you is garbage what
I talk on the Rogan podcast is garbage
this is what I truly feel in my heart so
for me to get better at jiu-jitsu inside
about in jiu-jitsu for me it's about
getting healthy it's about getting you
know my blood moving it's about just
moving around sweating you know and just
getting the [ __ ] out of here not having
calmly on my mind all the time I hate
when I have Connolly on my mind all the
time because then nothing gets
accomplished I can't write I can't do
nothing it's when I'm loose that I can
[ __ ] right you know yeah it's like
last night tried to write the whole
story about the colonoscopy and there
was maybe two or three funny [ __ ]
things like they give you pictures of
your [ __ ] to take home and look at
them in your colon and you're like what
why do I want to look at pictures you
bring them in not and bring a man I'm
not taking those out of the house I
think I ripped them up why would they
give you a picture of your [ __ ] like
they sure from the beginning yeah how
tight you my little [ __ ] tight that
[ __ ] was tight that thing that
thing is waterproof you can't get a drip
of [ __ ] water in there wind you know
some roofs have like a little gap
nothing you could see it was smeared
like it was spun around like it didn't
want and knew something was coming in
there it circled that [ __ ] you
keep it in your wallet when people are
on pictures look at my ass
looking looking we cracking funny
stories but no I you know I tried to
write it out last night and take the
funny experiences and that really wasn't
nothing funny about it you know I mean
but that was funny they give you
pictures of you ask yeah they give you
pictures of your calling they show you
what a [ __ ] where you love ten cuz
they pulled out three little things but
they were all behind there were nothing
that was just little oh so you got the
results is everything yeah ya know call
me today with the thing goes nah there's
nothing there he wanted me to eat a more
high-fiber diet
yeah there's only need a little bit more
lettuce but he goes it looks good for a
fat guy he goes for a big guy usually
guys your size coming here I got all
that Burger King residue on their
[ __ ] and you know fish and chips and
[ __ ] fast food and nachos and
burritos because you didn't have that I
told him I don't need fast food like I
really don't need any fast food at all
you know I'm sure I mean how do we know
why I'm asking you this but since I've
been eating healthier I find them
[ __ ] less is am i doing something
wrong
there should be sure I'm trying to eat
more fiber but let them ideas back I
don't know but I mean I figure I look at
you're eating smaller meals yeah so
you're not gonna take those horse shits
they usually do bleep okay you know I
was getting worried I'm [ __ ] eight
ounces of food instead of what were you
eating before 92 pounds of food yeah it
condenses you're gonna be on the toilet
for a walk yeah I thought you'd died nap
so obviously you don't decision you know
you cut all your time in half you have
to sit there
god forbid we talk about [ __ ] on the
podcast people get madness don't talk
about it was a beautiful podcaster you
brought up a father-son yeah though it's
a way of like what you don't know what
you don't fart [ __ ]
Lee sciatic Oh looking good this [ __ ]
morning on a Tuesday morning again we're
sorry about yesterday and you people
were sitting around going Joey it's
[ __ ] Monday
what's crack-a-lackin' here we can't get
rid of the devil and I was yesterday we
couldn't do the podcast in the morning
yeah that was wild man
and I felt bad I really did I like
Monday morning yeah me too
I [ __ ] love getting up and love
yelling and love listening to [ __ ]
music where's the music we play
something for me
play a little [ __ ] Aerosmith misako I
know you got something there already we
forgot that's right we fit we'll do it I
play with it this morning also
I play yes that played this morning oh
[ __ ]
as I
me yeah I watched a [ __ ] tremendous
movie yeah your tunnel it was more than
just a movie for me it was like [ __ ]
some symbolism something happened the
other night uh what made this the car
last could be easier was one my friend
Jim handy I'm gonna give Michelle shut
up he's recovering from my cancer I
don't think it's ass cancer it's just a
regular he's getting chemo done right
now is the main reason why I did this um
what made it easier I could say well the
people want you no no listen to podcast
a lot of people he mail me thank you for
those but we made a lot easier was my
friend Malan Martine has passed in 2007
she was the one that about a week or two
before I quit doing blow she was the one
that looked me in the eye and said Joey
you have to stop doing blow and she died
in 2007 at her at her [ __ ]
remembrance I went [ __ ] crazy on Jeff
Valdez and was gonna choke them they did
it right up but she got a colon cancer
so it made it easier for me to take the
test and I'm a big Peter Sellers fan one
of my biggest comedy influences is the
pink path that with Peter Sellers I love
those movies I love the physical comedy
I love his faces she always told me that
being there was his best movie being
there was his best movie you gotta watch
you gotta watch it
so last week if it's not [ __ ] on
Sundance being then I tape it and
Saturday night or Sunday in the daytime
we started watching it I had nowhere to
go I had to sit there so I started
watching it and it was Peter Sellers
he's like a gardener and his boss dies
and nobody really knows who he is and
blah blah blah and then he gets hit by a
car by Shirley MacLaine they throw him
out of the house and he gets hit by car
she brings him home and her husband's
filthy rich and introduced him to the
president the United States and
it just goes on and on and on but you
know those movies that you watch in your
ad keep asking yourself why the [ __ ] am
I watching this yeah you ever had those
movies that you like what the [ __ ] I'm
gonna watching this movie all the time
but you can't you just can't turn it off
for some movies I'll turn the [ __ ] off
this one I kept watching it going I
wonder whether this is [ __ ] gone sure
enough it takes me deeper and deeper and
then I don't want to give up the plot I
don't want to be that guy
all I want to say is the [ __ ] ending
blew my mind it was one of the strongest
endings that had ever seen the film and
his first well if his performance was
[ __ ] extraordinary because I had never
seen him do anything well I've seen him
do one movie when it was an early Peters
it was an early Peter Sellers movie I
don't know what the name of it is but I
watched him do this and it was just
[ __ ] amazingly to see this guy not be
funny he was not fun he was charming
when he would laugh he was charming but
he wasn't funny
was it was it like when was it to TT I
read at all at the beginning cousin
wants to take you out of it
because sometimes if a comedic actor
tries to do a dramatic role like you
just can't see it sometimes no I saw it
I followed him the whole way he was that
captivating that I follow him the whole
way and I had such an ending that I sat
there for what happened was you have to
do the medicine they give you the clean
you have to do a 5:00 in the afternoon
so what's it been at nine I got up at
2:00 and I drank the other half you have
to drink two bottles laughter - you're
not gonna go to bed cuz that's where the
[ __ ] really starts coming on Joe good so
I I watched it - I put on the - and
drink a cup of coffee
cuz four hours before the procedure you
can't drink any liquor so I just drank
coffee from 2:00 to 2:30 and then I
watched this film and it was amazing
that
that's when I decided to call Marilyn I
was so calm Alan that's when I decided
to call the store I've always said that
for you to grow as a as a writer as
whatever that you have to be entertained
sometimes when I'm stuck writing Tommy
I'm stuck in my personal life or
something's bothering me I try to get
entertained
sometimes it works whether it's music
whether it's self music I put on or
something this was something that hit me
I had a completely left field so it
entertained me so much that let me know
what I wanted to do whatever confusion I
had Sunday night I don't know why I
don't even know if I should tell people
is that you're gonna think I'm [ __ ]
crazy I'm not crazy whatever hang-ups I
had at that minute before the phone
ringing no I got my man Billy Corbin
Colin clay we're gonna talk about the
KKK cops in Miami and other things that
one idea for Billy [ __ ] called my
name Miami but it's amazing that
everything came into perspective the
fourth day and the more I'll know if
this ever happened to me whether you're
walking around you have different doubts
maybe a job maybe a relationship maybe a
decision you have to make and you're
having a hard time making it and then
doing something stupid or seeing
something just just looking outside
yourself for five minutes makes you make
that decision that watching that I'm
sorry what's happening beautiful good
morning good morning to you my little
[ __ ] ball of knowledge what's
happening a little bit of a cold I don't
think it's a bowler though but I if my
eyes start bleeding during the show I
might have to call an ambulance okay you
do what you need to do can you [ __ ]
believe they're bringing those a bowl of
people back here is that [ __ ] crazy
or is it me well first of all the first
thing that's crazy is apparently there's
a secret serum there's like a cure that
like they've let 800 plus people die in
Africa since February but all of a
sudden two white dudes two missionaries
in Liberia get it and there's a cure all
the sudden they send like this the
secret serum down there like I'm not one
of these conspiracy guys nor am I the
type of guy
that sees like racism everywhere you
know that's racist and that but what
else could explain it it's like it's the
cure that when white people get it
they've been hold it out like I don't
understand that's [ __ ] amazing cuz
they say that because they're giving
them the serum first I think so they're
like flushing them out you know before
they even ship them back here but I
thought the whole point of like you know
of separating people you're with a
disease and without is you know the
whole I don't concept of of that was
like if you have a country that doesn't
have the disease why would you
voluntarily introduce it into the
country like so far America has been
clean right I mean we've been okay and
now we're gonna bring fly people over
who have the disease it doesn't it seems
rather misguided I will agree with you
[ __ ] crazy what's been going on in
your world last week he called me what
guess hosting a radio show you always
doing something Billy yeah yo it's funny
I don't know if you remember this dude
Rick Sanchez he was like a broadcast
legend in Miami they were part of the
the big movement that changed local news
into the if it bleeds it leads
mentality into that era so his station
was revolutionary if you can call it
that in in that form of you know
shock-jock local news and he was like
the Howard Stern of that local news era
and he goes national as a lot of the
talent in Miami does eventually he went
I think he went to MSNBC then he went to
CNN then he made some pretty famous
remarks referencing Jews in the media in
like because Jon Stewart was making fun
of him on The Daily Show which I would
think would be an honor for any newsman
or a news person and so he makes some
remarks and the next thing you know he
gets shit-canned he gets fired from the
CNN gig and now he's back in Miami he
doing this this local radio show and he
just started like this Spanglish
language like local news comedy
type of show almost his own daily show
or however you say daily show in espanol
and so he has this show and it's
slightly I'm gonna say like
right-leaning it's a little bit
conservative cuz he's on the same
network rare radio station in Miami that
like excuse me Sean Hannity and Rush
Limbaugh are on and so I kind of was
asked to guest host it and I wanted to
bring it back a little bit more to the
center you know to kind of have a little
bit more of a drop some knowledge and
talk to some people who have different
views and you would typically hear in
the two hours before they have Rush
Limbaugh on so we talked about same-sex
marriage we talked about when you were
on uh you know medical marijuana
maybe some things that they don't
necessarily hear about on that show and
I'm pretty I didn't want to ever get
invited back on again so I I was like
let's just let's just drop drop truth
bombs all over this show for three days
while I was guest hosting it and and
that's what you did you always deliver
you always deliver you're a [ __ ] man
of so many [ __ ] things you know I
don't I follow like I don't even know
who the [ __ ] I follow on Twitter
everybody does anybody ring my bell not
really one person does and that's you
because every [ __ ] day you post [ __ ]
about Miami that you have to sit there
and go what the [ __ ] whether it's an
alligator you know it's always something
twenty pounds of blow found on the side
of this house the chick is dead on top
of it this [ __ ] only happens in South
Florida and for people don't know about
South Florida it's [ __ ] crazy
you know like right now we're living in
a society where you shoot a BB gun at a
school it makes Yahoo right away yeah
like anything to do with they don't even
they've gotten over Miami like the only
person that keeps Miami on the map that
tells us what's really going on in Miami
is you well you know I think about you
know the crazy [ __ ] that I did as a kid
and I wasn't that crazy of a kid but I
think about like what happens to kids
today for just doing stupid stuff like I
remember
my elementary school was like the local
neighborhood elementary school so like
we'd ride our bikes there on the
weekends and we would like hop the fence
and climb up on the roof and run around
on the roof and I think today kids would
get tasered to death for doing something
like that you know like they'd be
arrested for you know they'd be 11 years
old and get arrested for trespassing and
damage to school property and they would
ruin these kids lives you know as
opposed to just being like some young
mischievous kids who aren't looking to
hurt anybody but you're just kind of you
know filling the dead air between you
know between school days on the weekend
you know and I and you're right about
that like the second some dumb [ __ ]
happens it's somehow all over social
media sometimes it's even true but in
the case of Florida there is like this
is why we built our business here you
know our company we went to when we went
to Sundance in 2001 with our first
documentary we were like the youngest
guys in the history youngest filmmakers
at that time in the history of Sundance
who were the only guys from Miami
filmmakers from Miami and everybody said
we did like our movie like was on the
front page of the New York Post it was
about the alleged rape of a stripper at
the Delta Chi frat house at the
University of Florida and Gainesville
and the whole night's events with the
strippers and the alleged rape were all
caught on videotape and we put it in the
movie and so it became a big a big deal
because of how graphic the footage was
and people disagreed when they saw the
footage whether or not it was a rape or
a consensual sex act seeing the same the
same footage they disagreed about
whether it was a rape or not so um it
got it got a bit made a big splash and
then we did like sixty interviews in six
days and all the press asked the same
question the last question was always
the same they're like okay you guys have
been anointed the bells of the Sundance
ball bye-bye New York Post are you gonna
move to LA you're gonna move to New York
we're like hell no we're going back home
to Miami and they're like well why and
we said well first of all that's why you
call it home because it's where you go
back to when you're done do another [ __ ]
you know and second of all we knew that
this was like this town was just an
untapped resource of just so many
compelling characters and stories and
what's what's my old saying that now
that I always go
it's uh la is where you go when you want
to be somebody
New York's where you go and you are
somebody and Miami is where you going
you want to be somebody else and that
kind of informs the whole attitude of
the place of Florida in general like its
it Edna Buchanan the Pulitzer Prize
winning crime reporter once said it's
like Miami's like the end of the line if
you're running from anything in this
country eventually you're gonna run out
you know run out of time and run out of
space and in Miami that's how far you
can you can you can run in the truth is
we have a saying in Florida that the
further north you go the further south
you are if you go up to state you're
Miami is like the Atlanta of Florida you
know like you have Atlanta and then you
have the rest of Georgia you know like
it's that's what what Florida is like
you know we have Miami there's a couple
places that are kind of like you know
Palm Beach Broward and miami-dade County
are like the blue tip on a red [ __ ] of
Florida you know and believe me there's
nothing the rest of the state of Florida
would enjoy more than being able to
circumcise South Florida off the off the
rest of the off the rest of the state
and even crazier [ __ ] seems to happen in
like Central Florida and northern
Florida and that's why you find a lot of
the guests I'm like Jerry Springer type
shows but a lot of them come from roots
from Central Florida which is where your
KKK cops are from of course you gotta
break that down for us because when I
read that [ __ ] I knew I had to stop and
look 10 times dr. trust me it didn't
shock me I know it exists but when you
make it Florida you're home it really
hits home down there the KKK cops well I
gotta say I think by which I mean I hope
that this is an isolated kind of an
incident this is a very small town
Florida's got a lot of small towns you
know it's not just Miami and Miami Beach
and Palm Beach in all the places Fort
Lauderdale you know all the places that
people envision or come to when they
visit Florida like Orlando for example
this is a town Fruitland Park it's got
about 4,000 people it's just north of
Orlando which is course home
to Disney World the happiest place on
earth and just below Ocala which is like
an equestrian small country equestrian
type of community so Fruitland Park is
what it's called and and as much as I'd
like to say that it this is an isolated
incident even in a state as crazy as
Florida even with the police corruption
stories that seem to come out of here
unfortunately daily you really haven't
experienced the full spectrum of
Florida's insanity till you've seen this
photograph but I know you've seen it
jellies that notices it on Twitter yes
odds of a cop with his badge with his
gun belt with his uniform and then he's
got the Klan hood on on and the Klan
robe on top of that I mean it's it's
absolutely petrifying just this picture
alone talk about speaking a thousand
words but um what happened was this time
this department has about 13 officers in
the entire department that's the whole
thing
and it turns out that of the of this
small department you had maybe four
employees three officers potentially and
a secretary who was once married to one
of the officers were members of the Ku
Klux Klan
one of whom who actually resigned in
2009 I believe the difference between a
police officer resigning and being fired
is that they they I think they might
even get to collect a pension if they're
owed anything they get to collect you
know vacation days and because they
weren't fired they sometimes have an
opportunity though they retain their
like law enforcement credentials they
can go and work in another department
which is of course a frightening fact
but I think this guy's name is uh I
think the Google search would probably
kill him you'd think on future job
opportunities but this cop who resigned
in 2009 he was actually a recruiter for
his local clan um uh everybody called
him Kleagle zkk legals with a k' is what
they call these recruiters and he wound
up recruiting another officer in
Fruitland Park and that guy's wife who
as I said was a sec
Terry who also worked at the Fruitland
Park Police Department and this guy
winds up the first guy who resigned rats
out this other guy to the FBI and rats
out another deputy chief uh who's with
the department who I I have to tell you
something kind of funny maybe they'll
listen to this show and change it but
they like I said it's a small department
and they had not updated their website
on the deputy chief who resigned he his
picture is still up on the website as a
as an officer in the department which is
kind of which is kind of funny they're
not big on on the social media or
updating the the websites but you also
might have a situation by the way where
this guy this is kind of scorned the
former employee might have ratted out
one of these guys just to get back at
him
but the other guy definitely there's
pictures of him at a Klan initiation
ceremonies and of course because it's
Florida they had some crazy defense and
the guy said no I was working undercover
with my wife the chief told us to work
undercover and infiltrate this local you
know Klan group so that we could out the
other cop that Ana had already left the
force in 2009 because of because of
these allegations and then they asked
the chief who retired did you assign
these guys to this random undercover
work and he says he'll no he says we we
don't the undercover work we don't
really do it our level when you have a
department this small their entire town
is like three miles long he's like we
would never do anything any undercover
work like this there's no paperwork that
exists to to buttress this claim of
undercover work and it just turns out
that these guys voluntarily or perhaps
as a result of peer pressure on this
police officer and his wife joined this
other police officer in the Ku Klux Klan
and the real tragedy of this to tell you
the truth because I don't know that
there's been any documented incidents of
racism or anything on their part but you
have Cain
his cases that these cops were involved
in that they had to dismiss so
there-there might very well be criminals
beyond the clan beyond these cops
criminals that go free because you can't
rely on testimony from these police
officers because they're members of the
Ku Klux Klan I mean if you had a defense
attorney you pulled up this picture of
the cop in his uniform and his badge and
his gun belt wearing a [ __ ] hood and
you know with eyeholes cut out of it you
know with bedsheets on his head and
you'd say case dismissed your honor and
the and the judge would say you're out
of here so they'd have to drop any
criminal cases that these cops were
involved in investigating because
there's no there's no faith or
credibility in their testimony so this
is this is kind of the cascading effect
that happens when you have unfortunately
a situation where we're either good cops
go bad or what I think is happening more
often bad people are becoming cops you
know you have a certain segment I don't
know what the percentage is I hope it's
small but a percentage of people who are
you know either
now adjust it or power-hungry who who
aren't like you know good people who
become police officers to do the right
thing but they're bad people who become
police officers so that they can do the
bat they could do bad things and
continue to get away with it because
usually there's no accountability in
this case the pictures the photographic
evidence is pretty damning and and
they're and they're going down hey Billy
Liz Lee I produced the show this I'm
just a weird question
they let the cake dude I'm from I'm from
Florida there are no weird questions
they let the KKK protests now and it's
not like a terrorist group anymore it's
more from whether from what I've heard
it's more than that I don't I don't know
exactly what they do
but let's say this cop was up front when
he first started to let listen I'm part
of the KKK if they didn't hire him could
he like legally sue them and be like
it's discrimination like I just like it
is that is that even possible could he
have admitted to it and then got and
then been hired like you just I think
that's a very funny question and and by
the way we have so many lawyers in the
state of
Florida I'm relatively certain he could
find one that would that would take on
that that lawsuit because that would be
a federal lawsuit um interesting to
think like or the claim might be that
they're discriminating against him for
his involvement in this social club or
their political organization I think
because of the will see the the
well-known tradition of the Klan and its
positions that that I think that would
be sufficient grounds for not hiring
someone or in this case firing someone
because I mean you kind of have to not
have those types of biases that that the
you know that that the Klan is very well
known for so well I wouldn't put it past
lawyers in Florida because there are so
many and they're desperate for work to
bring a case like that especially for
with what we've seen I mean we have a
police officer in Miami Beach get this
this just happened last week a police
officer in Miami Beach actually last
year he failed a blood rug test a random
drug test he tested positive for cocaine
so they fire the guy right I mean that's
pretty simple it's it's you know step
one you take a random drug test step two
it tests positive for cocaine step three
you're fired it's over last week after
extensive arbitration he got his job
back including back pay of about seventy
four thousand dollars that while he was
along he had been fired so he's getting
paid back pay for time he didn't work
he's essentially been on vacation and
fighting to get his job back here was
his defense this only in Miami moment
his defense was a an old Cuban friend of
mine gave me a penis scream because I
was having some sexual dysfunction
issues in a in a in like a purple jar
then I don't know he bought at some
[ __ ] Botanica along with a goat and
some Chango Santeria candles he gives
him this penis cream that the man
applied to his penis and it turns out it
was laced with cocaine it was some
homemade concoction or formula the man
put just a strange unlabeled jar he put
this cream on his penis and it seeped in
the cocaine Lee screams seeped into his
system unbeknownst to him through his
penis and as a result he accidentally
inadvertently had cocaine in his system
at the time he took the test guess what
they accepted that defense they
reinstated him and he's getting back pay
so I wouldn't put it past anyone in the
state of Florida to get her job back by
saying come on I was just a member of
the Klan you can't discriminate against
me for that you know it's I don't know
if you know I'm CUBAN and as a child
nobody's perfect you know right as a
child as a child I got to go to Miami
and uh you know being from New York City
it was it was a different world the
lizards the swamp you know my uh my
family owned property in the Falls they
were they had the construction company
that built the falls pretty much they
would go specifically a hundred and
thirtieth Street and a hundred Avenue I
remember that in the ER in the mid-60s
late early 70s 68 69 I would go down
there my godfather will go down able to
bulldozer and knock down all that
[ __ ] swamp and and then they'd build
one house which he would move into and
then they built four more and it was a
whole block and after he sold the four
houses he'd sell his and he'd leave and
go build something else and while I
would go down I went down there from the
ages of four to about 12 he had six
different properties you know so I got
Mike so I went to red berries baseball
camp I you know he went to all the
beaches I go down and get tutored so if
I had a if I was doing bad at math my
mother would send money down and I'd go
down there I mean I was part of a family
you know they were my cousins and it was
really real and never ended up in
Florida being as crazy as I am
but I oh I've been to Florida from
Jacksonville all the way down to Miami
and I gotta tell you in all my travels
it is one of the most [ __ ] weirdest
places and I'm not putting it down you
know when I went on the lam in 82 I
lived in Sarasota for two [ __ ] months
of course talk about you know nobody
will find in Sarasota
yeah you know I think statistically the
vast majority of fugitives
come on America's Most Wanted picked up
they get caught if you watch that show
on this you know when I go on the road
on Fridays and Saturdays I enjoy it
because I get to watch daytime TV
something I don't watch I've got a
notebook I get coffee I smoke some weed
and I try to write jokes listen to you
know gangland and [ __ ] like that but
there's a show on one of those things
that I almost got caught it's on
discovery or something it's always about
discovery
yeah yeah one of those it's always about
I almost got caught and 80% of the time
they go through Florida I watched one
about a kid from new Brooklyn that
robbed the family and he went to Florida
and then when he was in Florida and West
Palm he robbed the sheriff's house by
mistake and here's the weird thing that
he was doing all this and night he when
he was 25 and he got arrested in 88 in
Vegas finally and I related it a lot to
his story you know he was a career
[ __ ] criminal and he's not gonna get
released till 2025 his Florida hasn't
because Florida will give you some
[ __ ] time also oh yeah we know we
have we have big private prison industry
year that's why uh-oh 88% of Floridians
right now this is the latest polling 88%
of Florida voters support medical
marijuana which is going to be on the
ballot in November amendment to vote yes
if you're listening in the state of
Florida but 88 percent support it 10
percent are against it I'm estimating
the other 2% were too stoned to respond
to the to the poll ah but 10 percent
that's it when was the last time 88
percent of anybody agreed on anything
for crying out loud and the 10 percent
who are against it Governor Rick Scott
who has an interest in private prisons
and in a drug testing company okay then
you have the Attorney General who is a
Republican who's against it then you
have the Florida sheriffs Association
who of course they're against it they
want to preserve asset forfeiture which
is a huge money generator for that which
is of course Lee
because the police can seize your assets
in the event that you are suspected not
convicted and not proven beyond a
reasonable doubt but suspected of a
crime they can take your property they
can take your cash they can take your
car they could take your home and they
can sell it for their own to profit
their own organization their own Police
Department before you are ever can be
charged might be dropped you can get out
and the police department could have
sold your house your car seized your
money etc so like there's no there's no
pure motives for any of the people who
are against the legalization of medical
marijuana but that's that's the state of
Florida that's that's just us here I
mean there there are no you know pure
motives of our I mean we had we had a we
have a governor right now who was the
CEO in charge of the hospital company
one of the largest hospital companies in
America who was responsible for the
largest Medicare fraud multi-billion
dollar Medicare fraud in the history of
America he pled the fifth he pled the
fifth on a videotaped deposition seventy
five times then he spent seventy five
million dollars of his own money the
ill-gotten gains he got from this
Medicare fraud company and and became
the governor of the state of Florida and
this is the guy who's the governor of
state of Florida to the credit of
Floridians the same shmups us who
elected him he has had the lowest poll
ratings of like any any governor and
they you know in America for the last
for his for his term the last three four
years but this is who runs the state and
I always joke I say listen if you're
gonna be the governor of the great state
of Michigan for example okay you you you
want a guy who knows something about the
biggest industry in your state which is
of course the automobile industry and if
you're going to be the governor of the
state of Florida you want somebody who
knows something about one of our biggest
industries Medicare fraud so there you
go you know what do they say in a
democracy people get the government they
deserve well bienvenido a florida you
know it's no eighty eighty percent is no
surprise and again my
proud of this fact but part of my love
for Florida was the drugs I mean when I
first discovered cocaine I was down
there in 84 83 and I had never seen
anything like that I never seen anything
like that in fact this guy who I was
watching that show the other day I
almost got caught went to Florida and
his first morning in Florida he says he
easily wakes up he looks out the window
and there's cops everywhere with their
guns drawn and he [ __ ] hides under
the bed and after five minutes if they
don't kick in the door he calls it's
1983 in Miami
he's do they're doing a reenactment and
he calls the front destiny because
excuse me I just woke up and this cops
all over the thing goes I don't worry
about it they just found you know 22
bells a blow on the beach it happens all
the time just stay in your room for a
couple of minutes and you know when I
went to Miami in 83 and these kids that
were my age maybe a little I was 21 and
there's these young kids tell me about
where they live is the inlet like the
end of the ocean and they would go down
there before school that was what they
did before school to see if anything
floated up they would tell me stories
about when they pull out bales of weed
that's how I got the paraquat at that
time I got a bales of weed was stuck
underwater it was salty whenever I
smoked the weed it was very salty and I
guess they sprayed that with paraquad
and that's when I got my lung infection
from Florida [ __ ] weed but it's
amazing how it's all look at the the
isn't the the pill business the biggest
it is in Florida correct
it was the pill mills there were more
pill mills in Broward County which is
just north of miami-dade there was more
pill mills for a while than that
McDonald's analyzation what's a pill
mill so a pill mill was one of these it
was kind of a throwback I don't know if
you remember the pain relief centers
back in the 70s and 80s where they like
sold quaaludes and it was kind of like
this this grain market situation so the
pill mills were mostly oxy right now
they're mostly oxy um which was killing
up to 7 people a day in Florida for a
while can you imagine they were they
were we were killing 7 people a day on
oxy on these quote legal you know toxic
prescription drugs
but but 10% of Florida's against medical
marijuana but meanwhile they had this
situation where you would go into these
pain relief centers here in in South
Florida and you would basically go to
one window where a doctor would would
look you up and down and say oh you're
not well you need a prescription and
they hand your prescription then he
would take a big step to the left you
would take a big step to the right to
the next window and you'd open up the
window and there would be the pharmacist
sometimes the same guy is the doctor
huija who just quote-unquote examined
you and they would fill your
prescription right there and these
basically just became kind of drug dens
of sorts and you had you had a situation
where people from Kentucky were coming
recover or people were going from
Florida to Kentucky with the with the
oxy they call the Appalachian Trail and
and the sheriff in tariffs and towns in
Kentucky said they were pulling over
more people with Florida plates than
Kentucky plates and they were bringing
up these drugs and people were just
dropping dead left and right and you
could just go right through Florida from
the pill mills right up the Appalachian
Trail as they said and and sell these
drugs and people were just you know
whether you were kids women whoever just
dropping dead from from from oxy and
they started to crack down a it took
years but there's always that learning
curve you know with law enforcement
catching up to drug trends and things
like that but this is a legal drug
quote-unquote legal drug you know FDA
approved you know your doctor can
prescribe it to you but they were just
basically I mean making you're talking
about making hundreds of thousands of
dollars in cash a week from from selling
these pills to to drug addicts and
children and that was a huge business on
in Florida for a while they have since
cracked down on it and fortunately you
know it's al it's a lot better I can I
can say that it was before how did they
justify it when before they crack down
because I I heard like didn't they not
like keep track of it so you could go to
like a pill mill down the road and get
the same bottle like twice in the same
day so like how did how did they justify
like that it was legal before they
started cracking down oh it was worse
than
you would walk in and you could bring an
x-ray it could be someone else's x-ray
the doctor would look at it upside down
he'd hold it up to the light and say
yeah yeah you're in bad shape here's
your prescription I mean these were
total cursory [ __ ] examinations and
then and also you have some of the same
businesses as I said selling the pills
there was nothing really legal about it
it was more of I'll say it was it was a
gray area a gray area of the law because
again these pills are legal they can be
sold you know through pharmacy and get
him at Walgreens of CVS in fact I think
Walgreens had a major actually was sued
by the federal government and settled
for a lot of money with the DEA because
of what they were doing in Florida which
is as you put it they weren't really
tracking who was buying what and people
could they were they were accepting
prescriptions from suspicious doctors
who clearly just had pads of oxy
prescriptions all ready to go and you
had people lining up out the door to get
them and then going to different Lowell
greens locations and getting them so the
DEA actually had to crack down on on on
Walgreens and they're America's worst
pharmacy I hope they're not a sponsor
nah but correct and that's just one of
the many reasons why they're America's
worst worst Pharmacy they also they also
moved offshore to take their profits
with them as well so they could make in
so poison to American children and kill
them with impunity but they won't pay
taxes or a higher tax rate in America
because they've moved their headquarters
uh offshore to boot but this was like a
gray area of the law that these guys
existed in Italy just took time for them
to catch up it's crazy how they make the
distinction because my first job for two
years with CBS the pharmacy in
Massachusetts and towards the end of me
working there it was the big the big
cough syrup and cough medicine craze and
I never really had to card and skin
licenses for people and they went
bananas like it make sense I mean moms
would come in with sick kids and maybe
they just walked over to the store and I
would have to literally scan and write
down the address in a little book and
make sure they didn't have they can only
buy a certain amount of that and that's
and that was bad but
it can have oxycontin stores like
7-elevens in certain areas here's the
problem with that Kirino there's also
scissor I mean you know you are you
gonna are you gonna take fingerprints
from everybody who buys uh who buys
cough syrup but this is the problem is
that we all kind of become criminalized
I mean I would go into this is a problem
that you know because one of the active
ingredients in the allergy meds of
course is necessary for the creation of
meth but you need a [ __ ] ton of it but
every time
allergy season would roll around and I
would go to CVS or Walgreens you know to
get some claritin because I'm you know
I'm clearly congested I can't breathe I
run into the store and the next thing
you know they're guys they need my ID I
need to fill out some paperwork they
need to see my passport I need to give
them an aspirin and it's like what the
hell is like it criminalizes everybody I
mean you need a [ __ ] ton of claritin to
make next yeah I mean like I would need
to I would need pallets full of it on
forklifts to to make meth you know if I
was breaking bad but like you know you
just want to buy some some allergy meds
or the next thing it's listen it's the
same thing with it's all it's all
security theater to some extent or
another I mean you can all be meth
dealers you know we can't all be
terrorists like the TSA treats all of us
you know we can't be you know but like
this is a classic case of your because
of all the problems that we're now all
guilty until proven innocent do you
think part and I'm uneven a conspiracy
theorist but man that meth is pretty
easy and cheap it's it's one of the
people who are poor might make meth and
people who do pills might be a little
bit more well-off do you think that's
part of it like they don't they they
they they want to keep the rich people
happy and and keep the poor people able
to just they focus on them like I'm not
even a conspiracy theorist but just
thinking about I don't know where a gum
comes from well you know it's all about
I think I think it's less about that and
more about the special interests because
of course the major pharmaceutical
companies are the ones who helped
finance Washington and finance political
campaigns they're the ones who own
things like oxy or they don't want you
doing is making your own concoctions at
home you know what I mean whether it's
whether it's moonshining you with your
with an at home distillery whether it's
you know creating your own at home drugs
whether it's grown
your own marijuana because then you're
taking money out of the pockets of the
billion dollar pharmaceuticals it's not
a conspiracy theory it's just a simple
you know it's a simple follow the money
I looked up that those that they with
walgreens had to pay eighty million
dollars in fines to end the DEA probe
that it allowed millions millions and
millions of oxy to reach the black
market they were to one for of course
always a florida connection as I said
but I'm so into uh six Walgreens
pharmacy more pharmacies in Florida
ordered more than a million pills a year
whereas in 2011 the average pharmacy in
the US ordered about 63,000 what what
one pharmacy in Fort Myers which is my
hometown
Dunc City baby they were ordering 95,000
pills in 2009 and then in 2011 they
ordered 2.2 million oxy pills so that's
what Walgreens
so they just ignored red flags as what
the DEA said I mean they just thought Oh
business is booming you know yes seven
people a day are dying in the state of
Florida but hey that equals millions of
dollars into the pockets of Walgreens
and they're not even paying taxes in
America so what did they care you know
it's hysterical that I love drugs
I could lie to you and say you know I
was that much of a [ __ ] loon I loved
it I loved getting high I loved a couple
lines and a valium and I hate the
quaaludes I hate the [ __ ] benzo I
mean I hate all those Downers
I ate a sixteenth of an oxycontin and I
gotta tell you I knew it wasn't for me
from when I kind of was so grateful that
your heart is still beating a sixteenth
why didn't you like it was one of the
roughest things it was like my pressure
dropped you know the color went on in my
face it was one of those type of drugs I
laid down I got up the next morning and
said you know what I've done a lot of
things that is not for me that is not
for me I don't want them around me do I
want those I could see Lea you made a
good point and I think you will agree
with me Billy pills are the [ __ ]
drugs
[ __ ] rich white people again pills
are the drugs you know if you look at
whose evening
oxycontin yeah it's a bunch of [ __ ]
junkies that's a junkie pill but what
about the other pills that we have what
about these ad D pills that people are
using miss using you know how to roll is
that we against adderall and all that
what about the people who chug down
valiums all day in the name of anxiety
because nobody has more anxiety than me
how the [ __ ] you gonna Chuck down ten
[ __ ] valiums and move around
what's his ambien drug that the last
girl that's asked if you know who takes
[ __ ] ambien not [ __ ] yawns not
black people and [ __ ] the Liberty
City you know and that's the other side
of it you're absolutely right bill yeah
we just we just had the dis judge judge
Lynn Rosenthal she's a florida state
judge in Broward County she was caught
on video she was she was DUI she like
she drove she was driving in the morning
from her home to work okay but what my
work I mean to the courthouse and she
hits a fence trying to go into the
judge's parking lot and the police all
of a sudden descend on her because a
bunch of cops around the courthouse and
it turns out um she was driving on
ambien she was sleep driving to work
this judge and she gets arrested
she also xanax on her by the way but she
swears that she didn't take it and she
wouldn't let the cops take any blood
from her ah to you know to drug test her
effectively but she did knifing believe
she did she took a urine test and she
was clean for alcohol so it was just
this uh this ambien that she had taken
she was sleep driving she could have
killed somebody she fortunately didn't
but because she's a judge they dropped
her DUI charge they reduce it to
reckless driving she was sentenced to
three months of probation 24 hours of
community service now imagine if it had
been you or I what would have happened
in that case well it was a judge but
always remember the prescription is
amazed the difference she had a
prescription
right by the way you're absolutely right
and to her credit she says that the
doctor prescribed her pills and the
you know the the the the the quantity or
whatever you know whatever whatever the
the dosage was of the pills were way too
much for her and she blamed the doctor
for prescribing the you know overly
powerful dosage in one you know in one
pill of ambien maybe she'll take a half
pill but you complain when he's
prescribed it she only complained when
she when she didn't really [ __ ] know
listen Hamby ons a tricky thing I've
heard just amazing stories but so is a
durable so all these pills that people
take you know adderall they selling on
the streets in that way I have a friend
that says he buys them forty lot or
something like that I don't know what he
spends or whatever so you know I would
say that that [ __ ] works though I mean
it's a narcotic it is dangerous it is
powerful but it works there was a funny
onion onion headline years ago that said
adderall receives honorary degree from
Harvard Law School because if you are up
studying or working or you know on a
work bender that [ __ ] does the trick man
but I know people in college who snort
it so it's not even like they're taking
it for like good the good ladies take it
just to get I mean just to give the
studying but their bloodstream quicker I
mean that's just that's just a
responsible answer something Billy what
are you working on what's your next
thing we're actually in production now
we did a you know we've done a couple of
them ESPN 30 for 30 dollars the sports
documentaries on ESPN we actually have
we have two of the of the top four
highest rated and are going for going
for our third we're doing a sequel
actually this is the first ever ESPN 30
for 30 sequel it's to our first ESPN doc
of the you which is about the University
of Miami football program loved it so
we're doing a sequel so the sequel today
we did we did cocaine cowboy sequels
what I like to say you know we might
we're not one-hit wonders but we may be
one-trick ponies
I'm not sure yet I would love to see you
do a documentary of a day in a life in
South Florida we
tweets I was looking at good tweet I was
looking at your page one day and I know
this is a [ __ ] movie day in a life in
South Florida that's the name of it from
6:00 a.m. and you wake up to sirens and
then every hour on the hour those things
that you post because you post something
interesting as [ __ ] every three hours in
South Florida something happens that you
go what is that that he just posted so a
documentary of a day in her life in
South Florida would be brilliant just so
the rest of this [ __ ] country could
see what happens down there because
nobody would take you would take any
hour of any day dude they Guinea
neighborhood to tell you the truth and
whether you're documenting a day in the
life of the neighbor or the history of
the near like you were talking about the
falls and developing that developing
Southwest miami-dade over there and I
told you I came from Fort Myers my
grandfather was one of the early
developers who was developing a place
called Lehigh Acres which is one of the
first like planned developed
subdivisions in that part of the swamp
and the first thing they did was they
build a grid which means they got paved
streets for as far as the eye can see
you know they have a grid so they can
start there's no houses there's nobody
else out there there's nothing out there
there's just paved you know miles and
miles and miles of paved roadways you
know that just grid throughout the swamp
and they would come out in the morning
the construction crews to go to work and
they'd find like a plain abandoned ah on
the straightaway of paved road because
it turned out it was the ideal spot for
drug smugglers to land because you just
had miles of just paved roadway it was
just like a runway for them and they
could land they could unload if they had
an emergency or whatever they can even
abandon the plane because the cargo was
worth a lot more than the plane ever
could they'll sell the cargo and they'll
they'll buy a new plane but that's truly
any hour or any block or any
neighborhood of like Florida or South
Florida it's like instant documentary
which is why we kept our business here
instant yeah I'm the laces of the
Coconut Grove improv when it was their
IP rest in peace
I went there from 98 maybe 99 to 2004
because before they said this kid can't
come down you know more but he's gonna
die in one of those hotel rooms he's
gonna die they knew what I was doing I
would go down there for two weeks and I
would just push my heart to the extent
of it you know and I'm not a
good-looking guy you know I don't have a
Corvette or nothing but I would walk
into that news cafe in Coconut Grove
yeah and I'd always leave there with a
crazy woman I don't have that magnetism
so where did you did you say it the mace
here where did they put you guys up
listen I used to stay at the Mayfair and
they used to stay at the one by the road
by the poyo trapper town us one or
something they support into a bad
neighborhood like after three they sew
crack there and [ __ ] right of course the
crew love is like that the Grove is
growing New Orleans you've got like
Bourbon Street quarter it's like you
know the Ninth Ward right next door yeah
it's not it's hard to believe if you
walked a little far south in Coconut
Grove you're gonna get a problem you're
gonna have a problem I had a problem one
night the intersection of Grand Avenue
and Douglas Road that's like the back
lot for the first 48 right there that
intersection I'm not kidding it it
wasn't good so they got off they knew
they knew that every time I went to
Miami it was two weeks of did Joey wake
up this morning you know probably in the
wet willies and and the dealers and the
people putting packages in yet but I the
stories I tell the craziest stories on
from Florida they used to be a bartender
at the improv that had a girlfriend that
was studying to be a doctor and she
would come in ask me for a bump blow me
and just sit at the bar ask me to blow
me guys again I'm no [ __ ] Julius
Caesar I don't have the biggest dick in
the world
one night I brought a girl home to do
blow and this girl said to me black out
she goes I never met you before if you
do a headstand I will [ __ ] you just a
boy could he do it no she left
standards of women I was hooked up to do
a headstand and she would help me with
the thing I was just wouldn't do it see
cuz I gotta go and she like let me let
me ask you this because because I've I
have some recovering addicts in my
family I'm not a drug user I'm not a
smoker I've never taken a hit off a
joint so much as as that not that that's
a bad thing I mean no no really about
medical marijuana I just I just that was
just a choice I made early and early in
life and I would sit around with friends
in high school maybe passing a joint and
eventually they learned to just pass it
over me you know they wouldn't even
offer it to me anymore and that's just I
grew up and I'm like why am I gonna
start now god forbid I should get sick I
would and my doctor prescribed it I'd
absolutely take it it's certainly safer
than the vast majority of the
alternatives or the medical uh you know
options this toxic [ __ ] that we uh that
we ingest but um and our and our drug
dealers in white lab coats pedal and
push to us but but my questions I always
hear this from people that I know in the
recovery community and people in my
family they say no matter where you go
you get off a plane you walk into a
restaurant you're walking down the
street other addicts and dealers can
spot an addict like people will just
come up to you and start offering you
[ __ ] you know on the street that they
just there's like a radar like a a
gaydar of addicts or something that they
can does that have that ever happened to
you like Pete you would just what and
people would just offer you [ __ ] because
they knew you were you know you were
looking or hoping that you were lucky
when I was getting high over the last
seven years do people approached me
which one well when you were getting
high oh oh you know it's they say that
has a big heroin movement in Hollywood I
never did heroin in Hollywood they say
there's a big speed movement in
Hollywood antenna pills I never seen no
that my my thing was cocaine from 1984
to 2007 Billy even if I didn't want to
do cocaine and mysteriously bumped into
me there was a point that I think I was
even curse if I tell you this you're
gonna the rest of the people who
listener they're gonna think I'm crazy
but I you
I'm not crazy when I take this cuz you
grew up with it there was a time in my
life from 83 No
85 to maybe ninety four or five but I
was convinced that somebody put a
Santeria spell on me to just not cope
because no matter what I did
it always bumped into me in fact it
would bump into me for free sometimes
even when that bumped pun is intended it
didn't all the bump point I mean even
when I got I remember getting arrested
bailing out and moving in with a
roommate who I thought was clean a
decent guy and I found out he was a huge
drug dealer you know I had luck like
that I always had luck like that that I
meet somebody and they'd say oh my
sister deals drugs oh you want to stay
that she needs somebody will watch the
house just don't touch the coke okay I'm
not gonna touch the [ __ ] coke I know
that's what my life was like for a
longest time I'm gonna meet my guy one
of my best friends said to me one time
use cokes
sleep downstairs if you need a bump the
coke is under the baby crib so you would
have to pick the baby up and go under
the crib and take the bag yeah you know
many times I picked that baby up like
stealing a car up all night long every
time I went mind the baby would look at
me and go I can't get moved no more he
was like a [ __ ] year old this girl
John Roberts and cocaine Cowboys the
other big cocaine wholesaler that we
that we interviewed and cocaine Cowboys
and then cocaine Cowboys reloaded which
is uh now streaming Netflix cocaine
Cowboys reloaded John said that he would
you know sometimes if he bring girls
over and have his girlfriend or she
would have her girlfriends over at the
house he kept moving the [ __ ] around the
house because she he didn't want her to
find it because invariably when he would
come home when the girls were home alone
he would find where little holes in the
bag where they would just poke a straw
into a kilo they'd just poke a straw in
and they would just snort right out of
the right out of the kilo right out of
the piece and but just be little holes
or the straws that had been inserted
it's it really is amazing the
that I did for 30 years the addiction
part of my life
then I'm definitely writing a book about
I'm definitely because there's hours and
hours of things that I can't believe
happened and they were put right on my
table I never really all I had to do was
basically go to a town get on stage and
do to cocaine jokes right that's it by
the time I got off the stage I go to the
bathroom and two seconds I'm in the
bathroom somebody runs in and asked me
if I want a bump and where I could get
some and that happened to me in every
standard economy too from [ __ ] New
York to West Virginia where I got take
him back to a trailer the guy thought I
was talking cuz I kept saying what do
you got he goes I got some [ __ ] that'll
kill you but you gotta follow me 45
minutes top of his trailer I followed
him out to the trailer when I got that
4:00 in the morning it was meth that's I
bumped into drugs every city I went am i
proud of that statement no but that just
goes to show you that yes other addicts
do recognize addicts I could tell a
chick I could tell a chick that's doing
coke that likes to suck dick that's a
freak I'll go up to him and go let me
ask you something if I give you a bump
gonna eat your monkey and they would
just look at me and go how did you know
it's amazing
it's [ __ ] amazing that's why you
should write a book is what happens is
it doesn't glorify it so much as addicts
will wreck it will read it they'll
recognize their own behavior and maybe
change it you know I'm you can see you
can save people's lives by telling your
story that's the point my brother always
a [ __ ] pleasure having you on here
always I really wanted to talk to you
about this cake cake cake not to clarify
that I wanted to give you my pitch on
the day in Florida and that's it I love
I love you with all my heart you like I
said I follow you and I read all those
tweets because I know that there's
something good you know you never
disappoint me they don't have May they
don't make me laugh they just make me go
jesus [ __ ] christ when does it end
out there you know I see Florida Florida
never shocks me but it always
disappoints me
I'll see you in a few months I love you
Billie thank you have a great rest of
the summer what's up Lisa at [ __ ]
yeah that's a great call that was a
great call Billy's very knowledgeable
and yeah man when your haddock [ __ ]
people will hunt you down let me give a
little something for my sponsors here we
got a new guy we got a new big guy they
listen to the podcast they like what
they saw they saw I was smoking an
e-cigarette they volunteered to send me
a package and like everything else
people send me I try and I read it I
listen to it I put the shirt on whatever
the [ __ ] you sent me I try I'm never
gonna waste one of your gifts in vain
and it's called a hip shake and they
sent me a box and it was pretty pretty
cute box you know the packaging but one
thing I noticed that it's the hit 1200
and it's guaranteed 1200 hits you've
seen me smoke a blue on here a blue they
cost 10 bucks and you might get a whole
day maybe a day and a half of [ __ ]
for 10 bucks I think they're charging 18
for these 15 for these where the [ __ ]
they are I've had this for four weeks
hmm still tastes good I got this eight
milligram one eight milligrams of
nicotine because they have different
sizes so let's say you want to quit
smoking you get this heated this hit
ecigs you go to hit eat six calm if you
want to quit smoking and they start with
24 milligrams of nicotine they go to 16
they go to eight then they go to zero
you quit and you quit for cheap because
their model is better tasting and it
lasts [ __ ] longer and I kid you not
I've been puffing on this [ __ ]
[ __ ] weeks and to boot they make a
cigar
they make us yeah that's 24 grams of
tobacco and 0 grams of tobacco this
cigar I don't have one on me I will
bring it on Wednesday it's [ __ ]
tremendous I've smoked a zero one and
along with nicotine in it and it is
[ __ ] tremendous the taste you don't
believe me we'll have a [ __ ] you
ever have a [ __ ] you [ __ ]
and they have a bunch of flavors - I'm a
got tons of flavor green apple they got
blueberry they got menthol and they got
vintage and then because we they have a
I'm a vintage type of
twelve-hundred is 20 bucks but it lasts
you a month
Holly cos how many blues do you go
through go through five blues no week
every time I'm putting either but these
they they have a 1201 which gives you
1200 two-second puffs and then they have
an 800 one for 15 bucks you see the
smoke I'm blowing out yeah this has been
a [ __ ] month already I'm not lying to
you I don't give you enough if you're
thinking about quitting smoking or you
just want a healthy alternative go to
hit ecigs comm see what they got to
offer if you like it go to the box order
it now and put in Joey's church what do
you get I have no idea where they give
you 10% off in 20% I haven't talked to
them in a couple days I call them this
morning to verify give this product a
shot if you're thinking of quitting
smoking
I do not [ __ ] you I do not give you
fake [ __ ] products this is a
tremendous thing you're in your office
you don't need to walk outside with the
rest of the stiffs and freeze your ass
well you just take two little [ __ ]
pulse mmm and there you are often
[ __ ] run it now let me tell you some
that vapor pens are like this I have
them at the house rabies you take them
off you put a button there you can
[ __ ] smoke at your desk and then
follow with a [ __ ] 16 milligram
tobacco who's better than you go to hit
e-cigs calm welcome welcome at least go
to the webpage take a look at what they
got to offer think about it I don't give
a [ __ ] think about your health think
about you know how annoying you are you
can't go outside if you live in cold
weather we're looking at the cold
weather
January's coming you want you might want
to start a resolution this is the way to
do it please go to hit East six calm and
take a look at what they got put Joey's
Church in there if you want to order I
think it's 20 percent how verify I think
it's 20 percent go to go to hit ecigs
calm today take a look
read at the information think about I
don't give a [ __ ] what you gotta do
you'll be there eventually you don't
want to keep buying these you know I'm
gonna plug this in twelve hundred hits
[ __ ] guarantee go to he the ethics it
says on the website that that 1200 is
equivalent to six pack six packs of
cigarettes that's a hundred and twenty
[ __ ] cigarettes you'll be smoked and
huffing and puffing for [ __ ] weeks
don't go to hit e cigs today why stop
stop [ __ ] around stop killing
yourself with this bumpin nicotine all
right you want to get healthy start with
honor
go to [ __ ] on it I got the shroom
Tech in the mail here then I got to tell
you some my knees not [ __ ] hurting
and I hate to say this because everyone
you ever go on TV and you watch a
product like sleep apnea they have this
thing do you snore and you can order
this mouthpiece let me tell you
something as family that mouthpiece
ain't gonna do [ __ ] for you from TV you
got to order it and they like Joe Rogan
they did the thing in his mouth and they
measured his mouth and his tongue you're
not gonna get a piece from TV and it's
gonna [ __ ] save your life okay I'm
telling you that right [ __ ] now what
was he talking about about on it on it
all right sorry about that I'm a little
[ __ ] stoned I'm a little tired
you're not gonna this is not gonna save
your life so with strong bone I'm not
gonna tell you of your knee hurts and
you need surgery the [ __ ] order it
cuz it's gonna take away the pain I
don't know what its gonna do I know my
swelling went down I've been on it for
[ __ ] four days my swelling went down
I don't have pain when I [ __ ] walked
I bent over this morning to tie my
shoelaces that's when I get that sharp
pain on it [ __ ] works whether it's
the alpha brain whether it's the hemp
force protein shakes whether it's the
[ __ ] ropes or the kettlebells go to
honor today you're looking to get
healthy cut this [ __ ] this is
optimization this is human optimization
I'm telling you I feel better when I do
the [ __ ] half a brain I feel better
when I do the shin tech and I go down
and [ __ ] wrestle with [ __ ] twenty
five-year-olds I'm not telling you I'm
not tapping out it makes me pick people
up and thrown through walls I'm telling
I'm more involved I breathe more and I
have more energy going on it press
search and get ten percent off your
first order they also have a program
stay on it calm weather the packages get
delivered to your house on the first of
the month
go to either today see what they got
read it tell me what the [ __ ] you think
all the sudden you get 10% off all right
and they deliver it right to your house
and you stay on the stay on a program
just like Dollar Shave Club Dollar Shave
Club
I [ __ ] love these people I love these
people more and more every day
their razors are a hundred percent
[ __ ] tremendous nothing cheap about
this [ __ ] you understand me why are you
going no [ __ ] bells and whistles no
lights no sprinkler for you [ __ ]
nothing just too sharp raises that
protect your face they shave your
closest can be and for the price that
you choose you're gonna lose strip on
there with aloe or cocoa butter
the [ __ ] they got what else do they have
week 1 wipe Charlies when I was [ __ ]
that liquid who's coming out of my ass
when I went to that doctor yesterday I
was refreshed when they opened up my
[ __ ] and put that [ __ ] camera in
there you know why because it's not like
peppermint you know you ever open up a
chick's ass and it's clean because smell
a little [ __ ] from maybe the day before
or something like that you eat it
no biggie they didn't have that problem
with me there was no [ __ ] residue there
was nothing why because I was using the
peppermint [ __ ] one wipe Charlies
yeah whether it's one wipe Charlies
whether it's two razors choose the race
of the package you want $1 $6 or $9 a
month two blades with the hallow strip
yeah you get a bunch of options do me a
favor instead of me [ __ ] it up go to
dollarshaveclub.com
see what they got if it's not up to
[ __ ] par I'm telling you one dollar
six dollars and nine thousand months get
razors sent to your house you save
[ __ ] time every month what do I gotta
do what's the box they put in church
Church CH you are CH you dumb
[ __ ]
put it in and get your [ __ ] value
today at Dollar Shave Club one dollar $6
nine dollar also for my favorite [ __ ]
people in the world I don't like [ __ ]
this stuff because they're always
changing they always sing me [ __ ] okay
this is one of people I deal with
HuluPlus you [ __ ] [ __ ]
HuluPlus
is so much more they got current season
episodes every [ __ ] episodes it works
on any streaming device Hulu Plus has
nice programming criterion collection
and amazing kids originals and you can
watch Hulu Plus anywhere anytime and
it's only $7.99 a month
what was that ly $7.99 a month that's a
st. Joe E I get the same deal from the
commercial yeah but you're not getting
two weeks for free that's why come in
cops up let go Joe Hulu Plus comm watch
original programming their daily show
what else they got since my show the
awesomeness is coming back The Simpsons
is going exclusively to Hulu Plus calm
stop wasting time go to Hulu Plus box
play impress and Joey and get two weeks
for free $7.99
that's what are they press Joey two
weeks for free $7.99 a month
why are you kidding yourself stop
[ __ ] around and go to Hulu Plus again
on Hulu Plus com Dollar Shave Club and
hit e6 com
I love you [ __ ] whats happenin
we like you shoutouts to my people jay
gomez you bad [ __ ] Ashley your
boyfriend set the [ __ ] send you some
he's been bothering me for days matters
Batman whatever your [ __ ] name just
get it together
Mike fish you [ __ ] who loves you
more than me inside Billy's head you got
a ball of [ __ ] with people flying Jason
see gods Jacob Ryu and yabba-dabba I
love you [ __ ] and I'm gonna give a
special shout-out to my main man Greg
powers and his Asian princess up there
and [ __ ] Seattle trying to get me to
go up then turn myself in this
[ __ ] offered to pay for me to go
up then turn myself inside I have this
problem this is why we I do not ever
want to hear that word fans again we are
a network bro we're a [ __ ] network of
savages and we're growing daily every
[ __ ] day the mentality is we don't
take [ __ ] from nobody and when we walk
in a room we got the biggest dick in
that [ __ ] room there's no
reason to feel bad about yourself if i
annoy you with my talk about the past
don't listen anymore I just want to show
that nobody's [ __ ] better than you
dawg these [ __ ] ain't better
than you every time you see me on a TV
show or you seem out of stage please
clap and please think because let me
tell you something I used to be a
[ __ ] savage and I made it this far so
when I get on a stage or you see my TV
show it's not only me it's you it's
[ __ ] you you could do whatever the
[ __ ] you want you understand me
stop looking at this people like that
Superman [ __ ] them they put that pants
on one leg at a time just like you ain't
better than you so when you gonna work
three and your boss is saying to you and
you're looking at along with it [ __ ] him
in the [ __ ] ass he ain't better than
you he just got to the job before you
and he may know a little more but you'll
be there in a couple of years don't ever
be [ __ ] scared
don't ever be something scared Lee to
say something to somebody when you're
right you're right you got to open your
mouth you can't go around bullying
people but you got to stick up to use
for yourself right I would be
embarrassed about sticking up for
yourself bro I was one of those people
you know when I had when I had these
problems at the blow when I promised to
get off the blow was because I thought
in my mind
becoming a [ __ ] anybody who can't say
no to somebody is a [ __ ] [ __ ] and I
wasn't saying no to blow so when I got
off the blow the point of my addiction
was to get balls back again and I
remember that I booked the commercial
for whatever the [ __ ] that was and they
didn't have brakes they have emergency
brakes in the cars because when they put
lights in the car for a commercial yeah
they [ __ ] mix the wiring up sometimes
so the guy dislocated the emergency
brake I told you the story so when I got
out I stepped on the brake to get out of
con the car kept growing and he goes
who's the [ __ ] idiot didn't put the
brake down and I said something like
[ __ ] you [ __ ] tell you [ __ ]
and everybody stood there in shock
the guy didn't do nothing to me and I
didn't get fired I stuck up for myself
when the guy came up to me later I go
you called me a [ __ ] idiot you treat
me like a man I'll treat you like a man
he put his hand out and I put my hand
out and we ship it there was no problem
right I saw him a year after that he's
like man that was a great night Long
Beach yes it was we giggled about you
people know when they [ __ ] up in my I
guess in my head you always go to the
worst possible like oh we're gonna get
an official fight and in reality
probably nothing would happen and they'd
probably be probably say sorry and if
they got in a fist fight what I'm gonna
do there I gotta kill you yeah they're
gonna bitch-slap you you're gonna push
them you're gonna fall down whatever
[ __ ] happens and you know what at least
then I go home and say that dude said
something yeah and that's the most
important thing in life you gotta say
some you know I have to say negatively
and I'm the remember one person who does
that sometimes I take things wrong and I
go at somebody in the wrong way and I'm
the [ __ ] guy I'm man enough to admit
it to them that I have that [ __ ] fall
you know that I have that [ __ ]
shortcut but but some people you gotta
say [ __ ] to yeah and whether it's a
parking spot you know the other day I
was in front of my house and I have a
big parking issue in front of my house
and there's a handicapped spot and
people tend to park eight into that
three feet from it if every parks three
feet from each other I lose two parking
spots and i sat there for ten minutes I
said sure and I want to play I'm like oh
excuse me I live in this neighborhood I
don't give a [ __ ] cool parts he just
parked correctly can you move this car
back man goes I'm sorry I didn't even
know yeah and I hear I was scared to go
up to him and because how I approached
to my six
I just gotta if you park this way and
eight people park this way
look we lose two [ __ ] spots my wife
is pregnant she's got all my wife has a
child not even a child she's a [ __ ]
human kettlebell you got this [ __ ] 90
pound child please give me a [ __ ]
breather so it's not what you say it's
how you [ __ ] say them right that's it
that's the church rolled up and a
[ __ ] bow it would be scared to open
your [ __ ] mouth especially if you're
right and especially if you're [ __ ]
gentlemen it's patting you women
I tell you [ __ ] to do it even
double than the men because you guys do
people talk in front of [ __ ] you don't
want to hear somebody says hey listen I
don't want to hear that [ __ ] and they'll
look and go look at this [ __ ] [ __ ]
but they'll respect you eventually a
couple weeks they'll respect you because
you said something honestly that's why I
was thinking about it because nothing's
happened with power but like I started
thinking like what if some guy smacked
Paula's ass and I'm scared to do this
like that's one of that's I started
thinking about it I was like [ __ ] I
gotta I gotta get over this so in case
that happens because god forbid
better that happened and I had to do
something listen man I don't go to
jiu-jitsu to break nobody's arm I don't
have no Mouse when I go to Jitsu I
really don't right you know sometimes I
grabbed Rafi who did this thing real
hard and I apologize Rafi I'm so sorry
no Joey go you know one of my problems
inside control and is I don't like put
my shoulder in people's faces even if
that's what you need to do even if the
guy underneath me needs to do you really
[ __ ] let me do it to you let 300
rest on your face let me just do the
side control thick that the guy you know
I don't have that malice in my heart but
I also want to know that if I'm walking
my daughter home from school in three
years I'm 54 years old that if somebody
comes up to me all I want to do is be
able to take him down and hold him there
and I'll put my three other pounds on
them and if he resists and I'll break
his [ __ ] shoulder but I don't want it
for that that's not what the martial
arts is about it's to you know control
yourself so just do me a favor from now
and stick up for yourself yeah well even
if even if it's if I'm talking with you
later on just say Joey this is what I
thought you don't have that chance on
the street but just start doing it in
every level and that's right
finally my son I don't do it right you
know somebody called me last week to
work a Sunday remember I was telling you
they're working next Sunday 10 years ago
I would have probably taken it and not
and curse myself on the drive down now
because I'm off the blow I have the
balls to tell the guy no no I won't do
and these are the reasons why because if
I have a bad Sunday you're gonna use it
against me in negotiations there hey
laughs he said okay he's not mad at me
put two other people done I don't give a
[ __ ] let them drive down another Sunday
yeah
always got a stick up for yourself man I
know we did sponsors but toking they're
just tweet them and I want to let them
know because they're new that he he'd
put in Joey's church for on-hit ecigs
and they gave him a free $20 pen
anything there you go [ __ ]
Joey's Church go to hit e-cigs give me a
shot let me know what you think I love
you [ __ ] stay black have a great
day and stick up for yourself there's
nobody else [ __ ] these [ __ ] now
the show's over don't forget to sign up
for your free trial of Hulu Plus Hulu
Plus lets you binge on thousands of hit
shows anytime anywhere on your TV PC
smartphone or tablet support this
podcast and get an extended free trial
of Hulu Plus
when you go to Hulu Plus com sighs Joey
or go to Joey Diaz net and click on the
Hulu Plus banner and don't forget to
sign up for dhal Shave Club com get
high-quality razors sent to your door
every month for a fraction of what you
pay at retail now go to
dollarshaveclub.com forward slash church
or just go to Joey Diaz net and click on
the Dollar Shave Club banner the show is
also sponsored by on accom go there for
new mood alpha brain anything like that
use code word Church to get 10% off and
again welcome to hit in 6 calm go there
use code word Joey's Church jou is
Church and get a discount it looks like
it's gonna be $20 off of your pen